Một trong những nội dung trong tâm là thành phủ ti điểm miễn dày phép xây dự
đối với nhà ở dinh lệ tại 1,2 sáng xác phường.
Với thi điểm được thực hiện kỹ tực kỹ kỹ quả có hiệu lực để đáng xác trước khi áp dụt
để nhé đẹp ngày và 1 tháng 12 năm, nhưng không tra em bày.
thành phủ điểm hướng chuyển dần thực kế kế phép trước khi xây dự
sang quan lý dự trên nha dự liệu về tăng cửa hợp kiểm.
Bởi vì cũng là 1 trong các giải pháp cả cái tụt của khoảng trính lưu trình khai trong đất cao điểm chuyển lù số.
Hãy nội cũng sẽ ra suá tải khi tế có thủ tụt có tần sốt phát sinh lớn,
liên quan trik tiếp đến hướng dân và sân nghiệp theo hướng đơn giản hồ sơ.
Giảm thảo tán chim mua trường số và không yêu cầu cùng các lại dự liệu đã có chính cơ sử dự liệu của các quan nhé nước.
thành phủ đang một tiêu một trong hình chăm mồ sơ phát sinh của 5 thủ tục đăng kỹ sóc dịch
và đảm bằng quyền sử dụng đất và tài sản.
Gắn liền viết được thực hiện chục tuyến phán trình.
Được với các thủ tục cần lấy kiến liền ngành thả nội yêu cầu ăn dụng mình tắc in lạc là đồng ý
nếu hết thời hạn mà các quan được lấy kiến không cối kiến phản hội.
Trong lấy vực viết đại hả nội trình khai được các điểm 4 năm ngày,
điều ăn thiện cơ sử dự liệu của gia vị đất đại chiến đại bàn bối khoảng 1.5 triệu thử đất.
Trong đó khoảng 3.5 triệu thử đất đã cóu dự liệu.
Sẽ hoàn thành chứng ngày 3 mười thảm bệnh.
Con khoảng chiến trong năm miên thử đất đăng đau đặt,
sẽ hoàn thành chứng ngày 3 mười tháng 3.
Thế hoàn thành phố đất cao điểm 1.5 năm,
sử dự liệu dùng trung, trường hóa và thích hợp cái dự liệu trọng nghiệm.
Nâng ca cho lần dịch vụ công trực tuyến và nãy nhé tính độ các niệm vụ trường đủ số.